l'orthographe c'est un problème ou pas
on le dit on le répète ici et là
l'orthographe n'est plus ce qu'elle
était à partir de là on pourrait classer
les individus en général et les élèves
en particulier en deux catégories ce que
cela laisse indifférent et qui ne trouve
pas grand intérêt à ce genre d'exercice
et les puristes amoureux de la rigueur
et du sans faute l'orthographe vécu
comme un sport ou comme la maladie du
siècle mais ce serait oublier les jeunes
qui vivent mal cette forme d'échec que
la dictée à eau dose ne guérit pas et
qui collectionne mauvaise note et
annotation négative dans ce domaine
l'orthographe c'est un problème
c'est pas mon point de plus fort c'est
pas ton poil plus fort ça veut dire quoi
je sais que c'est important mais
j'arrive pas à me concentrer sur
la façon d'écrire depuis que depuis le
CM1 j'ai l'orthographe c'est pas mon
fort jamais été fort puis
jusqu'à la cinquième ça n'a pas amélioré
quoi c'est toujours pareil donc des fois
j'essaye mais j'arrive pas
de décourager moi c'est parce que mon
autre habituelle c'est en sous la
moyenne donc je suis pas jamais réussi à
aller au dessus c'est une question par
hasard
[Musique]
quand on est petit garçon au collège
quand on est petit garçon
on se lave trop tôt
[Musique]
la dictée c'est quelque chose de rituel
c'est une sorte de de grand-messe du
français
il n'y a pas de bruit dans une classe
pendant une dictée même chez des élèves
qui sont dans d'autres occasions très
dissipées il n'y a pas de bruit et il y
a une volonté de faire attention de se
concentrer
qu'on abandonne dès que la dictée est
terminée
tu as toujours été ou
difficulté à ce niveau-là
[Musique]
c'est pas agréable à lire moi j'ai ma
sœur aussi qui ont 5e et puis elle fait
des fautes vraiment horrible mais quand
je joue au bout de 5 fois j'arrête la
lecture je trouve ça beau mine hein je
crois que c'est un
point sur lequel beaucoup de gens sont
extraordinairement attentifs
je pense qu'il s'illusionne énormément
sur les capacités réelles que les gens
de générations précédentes avaient je
crois que certains maîtrisaient
parfaitement l'orthographe et qu'il y
avait une part importante qui a arrêté
sa scolarité relativement tôt qui elle
connaissait de réels problèmes
d'orthographe mon père est toujours en
train de narguer avec son orthographe et
moi ça me dérange pas c'est-à-dire
itningue
tu as fait une faute moi j'en fais pas
parce que vous recrutez quand même à un
niveau assez élevé est-ce que les
problèmes sont importants quant à
l'orthographe ils sont tellement
important et il paraissent tellement
préoccupant que depuis maintenant 4 ans
ou 5 ans nous avons inscrit comme
première épreuve de sélection concours
d'entrée à l'école une dictée et des
questions de grammaire une dictée piège
une dictée piège évidemment pour les
gens d'aujourd'hui mais une dictée qui
n'aurait pas fait frémir un candidat au
BEPC des années 60 je crois que ce qui
m'a fait changer c'est surtout les
points en moins que j'avais dans mes
devoirs à cause de l'orthographe alors
je me suis un peu forcée à mieux
l'écrire mais bon en grandissant on
s'aperçoit que ça son importance je
crois que la langue française est
complexe tout le monde le sait que la
maîtrise de la langue c'est une langue
patience c'est un investissement et je
crois qu'on a trop répandu l'idée que on
pouvait apprendre la langue sans peine
sans larmes sans effort
[Musique]